Speaker 1: A liberal judge has won her race
for the Wisconsin Supreme Court.
And this gives liberals control of the Wisconsin
Supreme Court for the first time in 50 years.
Now, of course, we are going to be talking
about the fact that the failed former president
Donald Trump was arrested.
But I wanted to start with this today because
some good things did actually happen yesterday.
We also got a progressive mayor in Chicago,
which we're going to talk about.
We'll talk about the Trump stuff.
But let's start here.
This has been a hugely right wing Supreme
Court in Wisconsin.
Abortion rights are in question.
Gerrymandering related issues executed by
Republicans are a major issue that may indeed
come before the Wisconsin Supreme Court in
the future.
And so this is a very good piece of news.
The New York Times report.
Liberal Wins Wisconsin Court Race in Victory
for Abortion Rights Backers Janet Protagonists
prevailed in the state's highly consequential
contest for the Supreme Court, which will
now be likely to reverse the state's abortion
ban huge and end the use of gerrymandered
legislative maps.
This is very, very good news.
The defeated conservative was Daniel Kelly,
former Wisconsin Supreme Court justice, who
was trying to get his way back on to the bench
with more than 95% of the votes counted by
Wednesday morning.
This morning, Judge Pitzer, which led by 11
points, which is a very big margin of victory
now.
There were all these things about, oh, well,
she crushed him.
No, she didn't.
She's only up by 11.
Understand that in a state like Wisconsin,
which is as divided as it is, an 11 point
victory in this race is quite a walloping.
Quite frankly.
I don't know how else to say it.
A whole bunch of money was spent on this race.
And at the end of the day, the 60 year old
protozoa, it's is going to now make this the
first liberal Supreme Court in 15 years in
the state of Wisconsin.
I want to play for you a little bit of the
disgusting concession speech from Kelly.
This is the this is a you know, it this is
a tantrum sort of concession speech attacking
his opponent.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Brings me no joy to say this.
I wish that in a circumstance like this, I
would be able to concede to a worthy opponent.
Whoa.
But I do not have a worthy opponent to which
I can concede.
While.
This was the most deeply deceitful, dishonorable,
despicable campaign I have ever seen run for
the courts.
Speaker 1: Is he talking about himself?
Speaker 2: It was truly beneath contempt.
Speaker 1: Anyway, So a very bitter concession
speech there from Daniel Kelly.
But at the end of the day, we've been talking
about this.
This is what happens when you exist in a MAGA
bubble and you pick candidates based not on
what is actually going on in the country,
but based on what you think is going on based
on your tiny little bubble.
And we saw this in Kansas when it came to
the abortion vote, and they decided to run
an anti-abortion extremist in Wisconsin.
And Wisconsin is more progressive than Kansas.
Even Kansas voted to defend abortion rights.
So it's not crazy to look at these results
and say, yeah, that sort of makes sense.
You shouldn't have run the anti-abortion nut.
Also, you know, 2020 was rigged isn't great.
This same guy, Daniel Kelly, advised the state
Republican Party in crafting one of those
fake elector schemes to try to get Donald
Trump the electoral votes from Wisconsin rather
than Joe Biden.
We saw that that cost them a lot.
And this is this is what happens.
So when you look back at the Wisconsin Supreme
Court, you see a bunch of very right wing
decisions during the COVID era, the right
wing, the then right wing Wisconsin Supreme
Court struck down the stay at home order from
the governor, Tony Evers, similar orders all
over the country.
It was just what was being done.
They struck that down.
In July of 2020, the right wing Wisconsin
Supreme Court blocked a plan to delay the
primary because of the pandemic, something
that was done in other states.
It wasn't really like the biggest deal.
And then they struck down a mask mandate as
well.
And again, most states had these at that point
in time.
Eventually they went away.
So this is hugely consequential, Consequential.
We are going to see this decision.
So, first of all, when you when you see a
court change hands, you don't always know
the full consequences because you don't yet
know what may come before that court.
But we know that when it comes to the abortion
ban, almost certainly this is a court that's
going to have to deal with that.
When you look at gerrymandering, almost certainly
this is a court that would deal with that.
And importantly, we don't yet know what's
going to happen in November of 2024.
If you said, Well, it's Connecticut, I could
tell you with certainty this is not going
to be a consequential state in determining
who is the president.
Connecticut's just not going to be that.
Wisconsin is increasingly a flashpoint in
the we are going to try to steal it narrative
of the right.
And so the Supreme Court of Wisconsin might
actually play a role in 2024 in ensuring now
that we know who's on the court, in ensuring
that the candidate who received the most votes
actually gets the electoral vote.
So hugely consequential.
Great news out of Wisconsin.
Also great news out of Chicago.
Let's talk about that next.